what's up everybody good morning happy
with days of today happy Tuesday
gratitude journal livestream number
seven the point of this is to express
daily gratitude for me and for you guys
because when you are grateful you're a
happier entrepreneur and if you want to
go out and do amazing things happiness I
think is important part of it and it's
really hard to be hateful and fearful
and upset and depressed when you're also
grateful truly grateful meaningfully
grateful about things in your life and
so this is a daily practice that I do
with myself and my team I decided about
a week ago to bring this live for you
guys as well to share that and hopefully
get you guys into the habit and practice
of doing it as well and this has to be a
daily thing it's everyday
it's wake up and everyday be grateful
for something because it's easy to fall
back into your old habits and patterns
and you might get the hit one day but
you got to wake up and do it again the
next day just like motivation just like
remind yourself of your mission like
daily things that you need to do at
least in my mind to be a successful
entrepreneur and so I encourage you guys
to share it
those you're watching live share in the
chat those are you watching afterwards
share it in the comments three things
that you are grateful for today and
really feel it that's the second most
important part is that you're not just
listing three things down you're
actually feeling it you're putting
yourself there you know you're taking a
deep breath and spending a couple
seconds just actually feeling that
gratitude because making a list doesn't
do anything you got to actually be
connected to it so I'm gonna think about
the three things that that I'm grateful
for while you guys shared in the chat
the first one that I greet before is
child and salsa I in University I broke
a ended a relationship I broke up with
my girlfriend and she didn't like to
dance
and I like to dance and so we never did
one there we're never able to go dancing
together I thought you know what I'm
gonna go out and try this salsa thing
and I joined a school called Toronto
dance salsa that brought me so much
happiness and joy in the friendships
that I made
and later met Nina my wife through it
later became an investor later on the
business and as of January this year
became the 100% owner of the company and
just the people I've met the
relationships that I formed the joy that
it's brought the ability to have an
impact on other people and totally out
of the blue this wasn't something I was
looking to start a business or looking
to get involved and you know I'm paper
I'm I'm too tall I don't speak Spanish
I take big steps I'm learning as an
adult all these reasons why I should not
be involved in the salsa school and Here
I am now owning one so you never know
you never know what will happen when to
take a risk and so I'm really grateful
for all the years I don't know how long
it's been 12 years stuff like that of
trying to dance salsa the second the
second thing I'm grateful for today is
I'm gonna go with Tim Schmoyer Tim if
you don't know Timmy's got an amazing
YouTube channels worth checking out all
the resources and tips that you need to
become a successful youtuber when I was
really taking my youtube channel
seriously I subscribed to his channel
and he taught me a lot about you know a
lot of the basics of how to be
successful in YouTube and then I
connected with him and we did a couple
of hangouts on each other's channels
who's been on my channel two times I
want to say I've been on his channel
three times I think something like that
and since that I also joined his private
mastermind group that every week we
basically sit down actually later on
today talk about our businesses what
we're doing basically full-time
youtubers and we try to help each other
out and tim has provided a lot of
guidance and love and support and advice
and he was one of the first guys that I
made two collaborations with to and I
was so excited I got Tim Schmoyer on my
channel and I'm gonna be on Tim's
channel you know there's something about
being on somebody's channel that you
watch it's pretty exciting for the first
time
so really grateful for Tim and the
impact he's had on my life and I guess
what we're talking about mastermind
groups a third thing grateful for is my
own mastermind group I've had a
mastermind group for my business for the
past Wow I don't know maybe the same
thing like 12 years or so and these are
all entrepreneurs who have four hundred
two up to eight million dollar
businesses four hundred thousand dollars
to update eight million dollar business
and we meet once a month once a month on
a Thursday night and the party room of
my condo and these are guys who helped
me with my business to who challenged me
who pushed me who make me a better
entrepreneur a better human being
sometimes the issues you bring to the
group aren't always strictly business
related and I think I think the common
theme here with with my gratitude list I
guess for the day is the groups that I'm
a part of you know and that's for me it
being an introverted guy the salsa group
Tim's group my mastermind group having
having a support group of people around
me for business and for life that allow
me to express myself believe in myself
have the courage to do things I think
it's important so maybe a teachable
lesson there for you guys to to think
about do you have a support group that
you need around you for business and
personal and can you start building that
up all right well I want to recognize
you guys here in the chat and read off
some of the things that you were
grateful for we've got four minutes
before I head off into a league of
Legends business Q&A with my co-host as
usual Rishi cut TV first comment of the
day is Alexander Brody just with a happy
face happy face back at you man it looks
like a tired happy face
Zayn oh I'm grateful for my eyelids
there we go we're back to the body parts
with Xena this is a theme now it's
officially a streak my eyelids because
although it's not possible and I haven't
tried it myself
I suspect to be a lot harder to sleep
with your eyes open
got the Zayn of humor I know I'm not
supposed to say this about myself but my
own kind heartedness there are too many
jerks and people who only seem to care
about themselves already I wouldn't like
to be one of them
I love of men and number three sliced
bread it's so much more convenient and
easy to just grab some slices instead of
having the slice of myself I know
laziness yada yada yada Maplehurst
sliced bread I like it I'm a fan Antoine
good morning believe nation good morning
back at you Antoine Jiraiya's whoo
Chandi Chandi Chandi grateful for having
strangers in my life knowing everyone in
the world would be so messy
humans are difficult he he that is true
Alexander I'm grateful for a healthy
body my family and having a safe place
to live I love that J rise comfy for my
comfy thankful for my comfy bed pillows
sheets and shelter that's back-to-back
shelter here shelter safe place for
helpful supportive understanding
teachers who help us rise fast and easy
for cities would give us infrastructure
resources and platforms for greatness I
love it we feel that my driver is
finally out of a coma now he had a
terrible accident while he was on his
way to my place for work wow that's
terrible I'm I'm glad he's okay our hope
is okay we move in the beautiful weather
we have here in Montreal today Antoine I
love it trial is looking pretty sweet
today couple clouds but I'm excited to
get outside at some point gotta pick up
Hayden from school today so I'm excited
to spend some time out there but Veeck
grateful for good health and my parents
I love it what else we got
Rishi is here how hi I'm here a cup of
love I love it what else we got you guys
are all chatting with each other
Antoine gave you for my parents who
adopted me and let me become the man I
am today that's super interesting thanks
for sharing that man I don't sometimes
understand why those who want to live
are not able to and those who really
want to end their lives are stuck in it
forever that is
pretty heavy and I don't know that I
have all the answers but gratitude is
definitely part of that solution so SIL
Wester SIL Westar interesting I'm
grateful for my health the fact that I
live in America and my career and job I
was accepted for great start I love it
man what else what else finally Google
for your videos Evan to help me find my
expertise I love that Antoine thank you
for sharing that man loved Tim videos as
well currently standing what he does so
cool yeah I would anybody who's trying
to start a YouTube channel
he's in my books the best in the
business so I go check that out people
are loving Tim yes so much love for Tim
Rishi is a no yay for Tim I love it
finally found someone who understands
Nam name stayed namaste and I'm grateful
for that
it was his Felton right I don't know
okay whatever Buffy I love it new future
builder good morning party people good
morning new future builder welcome back
much I'm grateful for today when our
beautiful coach and friend came into
this world and he opened my eyes and
showed me all the success and joy and
love that has inside me and I rise up to
it every day yeah today is actually
Jason J rise fonseca's birthday we
celebrated on Friday when he was over
but today is the actual day so big big
ups happy birthday Jay rise in there
it's 9:10 that's it it's crazy how fast
it goes for you guys watching afterwards
again leave three things you're grateful
for really feel it and I hope you guys
go off and have an amazing day those who
want to join us on the livestream head
out to the twitch channel we're starting
right now have a great day guys continue
to believe whatever your one word is
gonna see soon